Thema wow
Thomas und nee Wer war noch mal in der W
Smudo ihr beide weil da wird dann immer
gesagt ja das sind so vorzeigespieler
die machen ja nur Werbung die können das
die haben ja wahrscheinlich den
Endcontent noch nicht mal gesehen was
für eine Beziehung habt ihr das habt ihr
wirklich eine wau könnt ihr das oder
also Thomas und ich sind große
Videospiel
Enthusiasten wir haben uns sogar
kennengelernt vor einem vor einem
Spielcomputer wir sind als junge Leute
im der Straßen in die Innenstadt
gefahren in die dadelhallen und haben
alle gedadelt was nicht bei drei auf dem
Baum war und ähm später begleitets das
als die Konsolen dann alle erschwinglich
wurden und ähm und sind Videospieler in
jeder in Hinsicht und als die Anfrage
von World of Warcraft kam war
ähm war ich begeistert weil diese Serie
ist ist ein sehr gr gutes Spiel ich
persönlich habe mich ja mit meinem ich
habe leider einen etwas Behinderten org
Schurken gehabt weil ORS können sehr
sehr gut mit ähm ich glaube wie war das
mit mit mit stark mit Kollen und so
umgehen aber schrucken nur mit Dolchen
das heißt der war so Art körperbehindert
und nachdem ich ihn auf Level 10 hatte
habe ich ihn so lieb gewonnen ich konnte
ihn einfach nicht vom Server kicken na
ja dann habe ich mich bisschen
durchgefüt dann wurde aber mein mein
Leben hat nach mir gerufen meine Familie
und mein Arbeitsleben ich musste woh auf
Warcraft sausen lassen aber ist ein
super Spiel und als wir dafür angefragt
wurden die Werbung zu machen waren wir
deshalb begeistert weil die Clips die in
dem die in der ersten Rutsche in USA
gemacht wurde vor allem mit Mr Tea die
sind echt sehr witzig und ich sage es
jetzt Kult
und eure aber dafür nicht na ja als die
Anfrage kam Michi gefallen die nicht so
klar da michi ist ja mehr so der Jacht
jaachtenkenner und ich warte immer noch
auf die ychttfirma die mich anfragt
genau na ja und kurz um dann kam die
Werbung und wir fanden das das Spiel
Super die Werbung ist toll und dann
machen wir mit gut aber du spielst doch
wahrscheinlich nie ich meine du lebst
auf dem Ökohof da gibt wahrscheinlich
nicht mal Strom doch W haben mit
solarzeellen auf dem Dach und erzeugen
den Strom für Videospiele selber ich
habe ein großes Kino wo man auf
Überlebensgröße zocken kann allerdings
habe ich gesehen wie smuto die ersten
drei Nächte seines Lebens nachdem wir
den Voucher bekommen haben also den
Gutschein für World of warc sofort drei
Nächte am Stück in dieser Welt war und
wusste der die werde ich nicht betreten
sorry ich bin echt ein Zocker aber ich
kann da nicht rein weil das ist wird
mich genauso fesseln und ich würde
Nächte damit verbunden ich verbring
schon Nächte mit Videospielen deshalb
habe ich das außen vorgelassen habe mich
auf die Werbung
reduziert und natürlich wisst ihr alle
da draußen dass es kein Egoshooter ist
und so und wenn man dann so Kritiken
liest denkst du auch so Leute komm
natürlich nur von nichtzockern die die
World of Warcraft nicht verstehen und
nicht gesehen haben und glauben das
würde sich hier um ein
gewaltvererlichendes Videospiel Handel
wir würden jetzt dafür Werbung machen
aber das brauch ich euch nicht erzählen
weil ihr wisst ja da gibt's schon noch
ein Unterschied zwischen dem und mtal
kom wie heißt es ganze Zeug nee nee wel
kom ist ja kom ach du weißt schon die
ganze Nummer von da wo im Zweiten
Weltkrieg hurra und dann gehst du um die
Ecke und schießt Leute ab oder
so World of Warcraft schon was anderes
ja kein egoter ne es kommt ja auch von
diesen Brettspielen her die man in 80ern
gespielt hat ich finde es sehr
interessant dass es natürlich gibt es
eigentlich also Vorwürfe aus von aus
kulturpessimistische Ecke zu allem was
man macht gibt's eigentlich immer und
mich woht allerdings dass man uns beiden
vielleicht wobei ich doch abseitig für
vorf macht dass wir mit World of
Warcraft nicht viel zu tun haben dass
aber man glaubt Mr t und William shett
aus den USA damit zu tun die die die die
originalpots gemacht haben und so vi ich
bisschen me her geholt ich gehe auch
nicht davon aus dass
wenn mir ballak die die bahnkar in die
Nase reibt oder irgendwelche andere
Leute die jurette aus dem Kühlschrank
holen dass S wirklich das muss man auch
so ein bisschen die Leute wissen no hey
das ist Werbung ja das darf man nicht so
ernst nehmen aber es ist auch das ist
übrigens ein Luxus solche Sachen so
ernst zu nehmen und sich darüber den
Mund zu zu faserig zu reden das ist
luxuriös und vonh darf man sagen den
Leuten geht's ja wohl ganz gut ja gut in
diesem Sinne vielen Dank danke
schön